schwarz und blau
die neue politische landkarte in sachsen
besteht vor allem aus zwei farben
die fdp gewinnt nach der cdu die meisten
direktmandate und welche gründe geben
die fdp an
70 prozent in sachsen antworten die afg
wegen ihrer politischen forderungen
gewählt zu haben
28 prozent sprechen von einem denkzettel
auch die karte in brandenburg teilt sich
nach der landtagswahl in vor allem zwei
farben auf rot und blau
die spd musste zwar verluste hinnehmen
bleibt aber stärkste kraft und hier
geben 53 prozent der befragten an die
fdp als denkzettel welt zu haben 43
prozent sagen dagegen die wahl fiel
wegen ihrer inhalte auf die ofd
auffällig rechtsfällen vor allem die
ländlichen regionen sagt auch professor
gideon botsch politikwissenschaftler an
der uni potsdam
hier muss man den demokratischen
parteien meines erachtens tatsächlich
vorhalten dass sie sich oft aus dieser
fläche auswahl arithmetischen gründen
zurückziehen dass sie meinen hier finden
wir ohnehin nicht genug wählerinnen und
wähler da müssen wir gar nicht im
wahlkampf freien und hier dürfte
durchaus eine erfolgreiche kampagne
gefahren
aber wer wählt die afd in beiden
bundesländern ist sie bei männern
deutlich erfolgreicher als bei frauen
sieht man sich die altersgruppen an ist
die fd in beiden bundesländern bei den
wählern unter 60 jahren mit abstand die
stärkste partei
gründe für ihren erfolg protest
benachteiligung und unzufriedenheit in
brandenburg sagen 46 prozent der fdp
wähler haben im leben weniger als ihnen
gerechterweise zusteht
in sachsen sagen 70 die ostdeutschen
werden behandelt wie bürger zweiter
klasse
das ist natürlich tatsächlich so dass
wir im osten einige benachteiligung zur
kenntnis nehmen müssen
das fängt mit dem unterschiedlichen
löhnen und gehältern bei gleich habe ein
wenig höheren preisniveau an mit
infrastruktur problemen und förderungs
problemen wie viele bundesbehörden gibt
es in den neuen ländern und so weiter
und so fort ja wie viele der
ostdeutschen hauptstädte sind überhaupt
noch mit dem ece angeschlossen dann
müssen sie wie beispielsweise nach
schwerin oder magdeburg den
regionalexpress nehmen das sind
natürlich alles faktoren die die dakar
zu buche schlagen und woher kommen die
neuen stimmen für die afd von früheren
cdu wählern und von früheren
nichtwählern keine andere partei
profitiert also so stark von der
gestiegenen wahlbeteiligung bieten afd
[Musik]